Creemos que las computadoras cuánticas nos permitirán resolver algunos problemas más rápido de lo que podemos con computadoras clásicas solas. Pero
entender cómo es algo sutil. Hoy en Qiskit en el aula, intentaremos descubrir el origen del poder de
la computación cuántica mirando uno de los primeros
algoritmos. Bienvenido a Qiskit en el aula. En esta serie, usaremos Qiskit para explorar algunos conceptos fundamentales
que se tratan comúnmente en cursos relacionados con la computación cuántica. Cada video viene acompañado de un módulo interactivo
vinculado en la descripción de abajo. Así que asegúrate de revisarlo. Si has escuchado mucho sobre las computadoras cuánticas,
probablemente hayas oído que pueden usar fenómenos cuánticos como la superposición, el entrelazamiento y la interferencia para resolver
problemas de maneras que las computadoras clásicas no pueden. Pero ¿cómo exactamente ayudan estas características? En 1985, David Deutsch fue el
primero en mostrar cómo podría ocurrir esto. Propuso lo que hoy se conoce como el algoritmo de Deutsch, que podía resolver un
problema de forma más eficiente que cualquier algoritmo clásico. Hoy, veremos el algoritmo de Deutsch y
una extensión posterior llamada el algoritmo Deutsch-Jozsa, y examinaremos cómo los aspectos únicamente cuánticos de los qubits
pueden usarse en beneficio de las computadoras cuánticas. Luego ejecutaremos estos algoritmos en una computadora cuántica real con Qiskit.
Existen otros algoritmos cuánticos que también muestran una ventaja teórica sobre los algoritmos clásicos conocidos. Y no todos funcionan
con los mismos principios que los que veremos hoy. Así que lo que aprenderemos hoy no explica en general cómo funciona una computadora cuántica,
pero sí nos ayuda a empezar a ver cómo los principios de la mecánica cuántica pueden combinarse para
crear una poderosa computadora cuántica. Antes de adentrarnos en el algoritmo de Deutsch, pensemos primero en cómo las computadoras cuánticas
son diferentes de las computadoras clásicas y cómo eso podría darnos ventaja para resolver ciertos
problemas. Una diferencia es que los bits cuánticos llamados qubits pueden estar en estados de superposición. En lugar de estar
limitados al estado cero o al estado uno como un bit clásico, un qubit
puede estar en un estado de superposición de cero y uno. Escribimos este estado así,
donde a y b son números complejos cuyos cuadrados suman uno, y cuantos más
qubits, más se amplía esta brecha. Dos bits clásicos solo pueden estar en uno de estos
cuatro estados posibles: 0 0, 1 1, 0 1 o 1
1. Dos qubits pueden estar en una superposición de los cuatro estados permitidos clásicamente, lo cual se
escribe así. En general, un sistema clásico de n bits solo puede estar en uno de los 2 elevado a n posibles
combinaciones de ceros y unos. Un sistema cuántico de n qubits puede estar en una superposición de todos los 2 elevado a n de estos
estados. La escala es exponencial. Así que incluso si tuviéramos solo 10 qubits, podrían
estar en un estado de superposición de 2 elevado a 10, que son 1.024 posibles combinaciones de ceros y
unos. La escala exponencial del espacio de estados de los qubits se denomina
paralelismo cuántico y es parcialmente responsable de la ventaja de las computadoras cuánticas sobre las clásicas. Pero una computadora cuántica
no es solo un procesador masivamente paralelo. El hecho de que los qubits en una computadora cuántica puedan estar en una
superposición de exponencialmente muchos estados no significa que tengamos acceso a toda la información en cada uno de estos
estados. Dado que la medición colapsa el sistema a un estado u otro,
veamos cómo se desarrolla esto en un problema simple. Supón que hay una máquina a la que
puedes alimentar con un solo bit. Luego aplica alguna función al bit y devuelve otro bit. La máquina
está dentro de una caja negra a la que no podemos acceder. Todo a lo que tenemos acceso es el bit
que le damos, x, y el bit que la caja devuelve, f
de x. Queremos descubrir cuál es la función f que la máquina está aplicando.
Hay cuatro funciones posibles que toman un solo bit y producen otro bit.
Entonces, para averiguar cuál es la función, podemos darle un cero y ver si devuelve un cero o un uno; luego darle
un uno y hacer lo mismo. Cada uno de estos dos pasos se llama una consulta. Esta
es una forma de comparar algoritmos clásicos y cuánticos a través del llamado modelo de consultas, donde comparamos el número
de consultas que cada uno de los algoritmos necesita hacer a la caja negra para resolver el problema. Así que en este caso, nuestro
método clásico necesitó consultar la caja dos veces para aprender la función. Veamos si podemos hacerlo mejor si una computadora cuántica
consulta la caja negra. En vez de primero dar un cero y luego un uno, la
computadora cuántica puede darle a la caja un qubit que está en superposición de cero y
uno. Así que en efecto, le estamos dando a la caja ambas entradas con una sola consulta. Entonces,
¿eso significa que podemos aprender la función con solo una consulta?
Lamentablemente, ese no es el caso. Vemos por qué esta idea falla cuando la probamos en una computadora cuántica. Haremos un
circuit con dos qubits. El qubit cero, representado aquí por esta línea superior, será nuestro estado de entrada X que le damos al
black box que se muestra aquí por el gate de color marrón etiquetado UF. El gate UF es
diseñado para tomar el qubit cero como el estado de entrada X, luego aplicar una transformación en el qubit uno que toma
el estado cero al estado f de x. Así que mientras el qubit 1 haya empezado en el estado
cero, la salida es x en el qubit 0 y f de x en el qubit 1. Para encontrar f de x para
ambos x=0 y x=1 simultáneamente, podemos intentar poner el qubit 0 en una superposición de 0 y 1 antes de
introducirlo en la caja negra. Eso se hace con este gate Hadamard rojo que transforma el estado cero a 1 / 2
0 + 1. Así que después del gate de la caja negra, deberíamos tener una superposición de ambos
f de 0 y f de 1 en el qubit 1. Cuando medimos los dos qubits, esperamos
responder la pregunta: ¿qué función está dentro de la caja negra? Usemos el sampler primitivo de Qiskit para ejecutar el
circuit y devolver el resultado. Podemos elegir el número de veces que se ejecuta el circuit, llamado muestras, cambiando este
parámetro llamado shots aquí.
Esto equivale al número de consultas que hacemos a la caja negra. Veamos si con una sola consulta será
suficiente. Aquí está el resultado. Medimos el qubit 0 como cero. Ese fue el
valor de entrada x y el qubit 1 como 1, que fue el valor de salida f de x. Así que ahora
sabemos que f de 0 es igual a 1. ¿Pero qué hay de f de 1? Aquí es donde está el problema. Una vez que
medimos el estado, las superposiciones colapsaron y solo pudimos medir una parte de la función con una
sola consulta. Esto no nos dice todo lo que necesitamos saber para determinar qué función es. Necesitaríamos una
segunda consulta a la caja para eso. Así que aunque el principio del paralelismo cuántico nos permite simultáneamente
hacer que la caja negra evalúe f de 0 y f de 1, no tenemos acceso a ambas
respuestas. El paralelismo cuántico por sí solo no es suficiente. El algoritmo de Deutsch
muestra cómo podemos usar el paralelismo cuántico de forma un poco diferente para aprender sobre la función dentro de la caja negra. No podremos
saber exactamente cuál es la función, pero sí podremos aprender algo nuevo sobre ella con una
sola consulta que no podríamos con una computadora clásica. Empecemos mirando una tabla de las cuatro posibles
funciones que llevan un solo bit a otro bit. Aquí puedes ver que dos de las funciones f_sub_1 y f_sub_4 siempre
devuelven un único valor independientemente del estado de entrada. Llamamos a estas dos funciones
constantes. f_sub_2 y f_sub_3 devuelven cero o uno dependiendo de
el estado de x. Llamamos a estas dos funciones balanceadas. El algoritmo de Deutsch
determina si la función es constante o balanceada haciendo algunos ajustes inteligentes al circuit que usamos
antes. Aquí está el circuit. Comienza preparando el qubit 0 en el estado 1 /
2 0 + 1 con un Hadamard como antes, y el qubit 1 en el estado 1 / 2 0 - 1
con un gate NOT seguido de un Hadamard.
Así que el estado completo en este punto aquí es donde esto es el estado del qubit 0 y
esto es el estado del qubit 1. Preparar el qubit 1 de esta manera en lugar de simplemente
dejarlo en el estado cero permite que el algoritmo use el paralelismo cuántico en combinación con la interferencia para aprender
sobre la función de la caja negra. Veamos qué ocurre cuando los qubits se introducen en UF, el gate de la caja negra: pueden pasar un par de cosas.
Si la función es constante, entonces la caja negra realizará alguna operación sobre el qubit 1 solo, independientemente
del estado de cero. En este caso, como UF no toca el qubit cero ni
le importa su estado, el segundo Hadamard aquí simplemente deshace lo que
hizo el primer Hadamard. Y mediremos el qubit en el estado cero. Veamos la función balanceada f_sub_2 como ejemplo para ver
qué le hace uf al estado en este caso. Cuando x es cero, f de x es cero, y cuando x
es 1, f de x es 1. Recuerda lo que te dije sobre el gate uf. Toma el qubit 0
como nuestro estado de entrada x y produce f de x en el qubit 1, asumiendo que el qubit 1
empezó en el estado cero. Así que para esta función lo que UF le hace al qubit 1 depende
del qubit 0. Si 0 es cero, entonces el qubit 1 quedará en el estado cero para obtener f
de x = 0. Si el qubit 0 es 1, la caja negra aplicará un gate NOT al qubit 1 y lo pondrá
en el estado uno. Así obtenemos f de 1 igual a 1. Esto es exactamente lo que hace un CNOT o gate CNOT. Un
gate CNOT toma dos qubits, un qubit de control y un qubit objetivo, y voltea el
estado del qubit objetivo si el qubit de control está en el estado uno. Pero no hace nada al objetivo si el control
qubit está en el estado cero. Así que UF para F2 es simplemente un CNOT en Q0 y Q1. El
gate CNOT no hará nada al primer término ya que el qubit de control está en el estado cero. Pero en el segundo término, este
cero se voltea a uno y este uno se voltea a cero. Y si factorizamos un signo menos, veremos que el estado del qubit 1 es
el que no cambia. Pero este término ha tomado un signo menos. Así que el estado del qubit 0 es
en realidad el que ha cambiado. Pasó de ser 0 + 1 a ser 0 menos
1. Cuando aplicamos el Hadamard final al qubit 0, esto lo transforma al estado 1. Así que si la función en la caja negra
es f_sub_2, mediremos un uno en lugar de un cero. Resulta que el gate UF para la otra función balanceada f3 es el
el mismo gate CNOT seguido de un NOT en el qubit 1. Ese gate NOT final no afecta al qubit cero. Así que cuando la función
está balanceada, mediremos el qubit 0 en el estado uno al final del circuit. Ahora, si no seguiste todo esto,
está bien. Te sugiero que lo repases por tu cuenta para ver cómo funciona. El punto principal aquí es lo que
ocurrió cuando aplicamos el CNOT para las dos funciones balanceadas. El qubit 0 solo se usó como qubit de control para cambiar
el estado del qubit 1. Intuitivamente, podrías pensar que el qubit 0 permanecería sin cambios. Y sin embargo, de algún modo nuestras
operaciones sobre el qubit uno en realidad cambian el estado del qubit cero al modificar la fase relativa entre las dos partes de
su superposición. Este fenómeno se conoce como el mecanismo de retroceso de fase y es
sumamente contraintuitivo, como muchos fenómenos cuánticos. De cierta manera, puedes pensar en el mecanismo de retroceso de fase
como remar en un bote. El acto de empujar el agua hacia atrás en realidad te impulsa hacia adelante. Igual que las operaciones sobre el
qubit 1 en realidad cambian el qubit cero. Ahora podemos ejecutar el algoritmo de Deutsch en
Qiskit. Aquí podemos seleccionar qué función poner dentro de la caja negra, que hemos elegido que sea F3. Este es el
diagrama del circuit del algoritmo y podemos ejecutarlo como antes con el primitivo sampler. Estableceremos el número de
muestras en solo uno y veremos qué medimos. En este caso, medimos uno.
Entonces, sabemos que la función era balanceada, que es justo lo que esperábamos, ya que la caja negra contenía la función f3. Así que con una sola
consulta, pudimos diferenciar entre estas dos clases de funciones.
Un algoritmo clásico habría necesitado dos consultas para determinarlo. Esto muestra una modesta ventaja de la computación cuántica
sobre la computación clásica, pero no es muy impresionante. Solo uno contra dos. Pero el algoritmo de Deutsch
sigue siendo extremadamente importante en la historia de la computación cuántica porque proporcionó la chispa que llevó a otros
a pensar en algoritmos cuánticos más grandes y sofisticados.
Esto incluye una extensión multicubit del algoritmo de Deutsch que demuestra una ventaja cuántica mucho más impresionante.
Esto se llama el algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa. Resuelve un problema similar, pero en este caso, la función de la caja negra
sobre la que queremos aprender toma n bits como entrada y devuelve un único bit. Como
antes, se nos garantiza que la función es constante, lo que significa que el bit de salida es siempre uno o siempre cero,
independientemente de la cadena de bits de entrada, o balanceada, lo que significa que la salida es cero para
la mitad de las cadenas de bits de entrada y uno para la otra mitad. Por supuesto, existen otras
funciones que toman n bits a un único bit que no son ni constantes ni balanceadas. Pero en este problema, se nos
garantiza que ninguna de esas funciones está dentro de la caja negra. La que está en la caja está garantizada que es constante
o balanceada. El circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa es similar al algoritmo de Deutsch, pero con más qubits. Aquí tenemos una
implementación del algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa para aprender sobre una función de tres bits. Esta vez tenemos tres qubits
para el estado de entrada en lugar de solo uno. Y luego tenemos este último qubit para el estado de salida. Como antes, también
preparamos todos los qubits de entrada para estar en el estado 0 + uno y el qubit de salida
para estar en el estado 0 menos uno. Luego, aunque las matemáticas son un poco más complicadas de seguir, el principio
sigue siendo el mismo. Si la función es constante, no dependerá de los tres qubits superiores en absoluto. Así que sus estados
se transformarán de nuevo a cero después de los segundos Hadamard y nuestra medición dará una cadena de tres bits de todos
ceros. Pero si la función es balanceada, cuando midamos los qubits tras los Hadamard, el mecanismo de retroceso de fase
hará que uno o más de esos bits sea uno. Puede que no sea tan fácil verlo esta vez, pero si trabajas
cada paso por tu cuenta, pronto verás que esto debe ser así. Una forma de comprobarlo es intentar calcular la
probabilidad de medir todos ceros con una función balanceada. Deberías obtener una probabilidad de cero. Ejecutemos el
algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa en una computadora cuántica con Qiskit. El paso más difícil es probablemente crear la función de Deutsch-Jozsa.
Esa será nuestra caja negra que consultamos aquí. Este código produce una función de Deutsch-Jozsa aleatoria que está
garantizada a ser balanceada o constante. Luego construimos nuestro circuit de Deutsch-Jozsa insertando nuestra caja negra
aquí. De nuevo, ejecutamos el circuit con el sampler y después de medir, examinamos
los bits medidos para determinar si la función era balanceada o constante.
Si todos son cero, es constante. Pero si hay al menos un bit uno en la cadena, entonces es balanceada. En este
caso, obtenemos una cadena de bits de 1 uno uno.
Así que sabemos que la función era balanceada. Espero haberte dado tu primer vistazo a cómo los algoritmos cuánticos
pueden aprovechar fenómenos cuánticos interesantes y a menudo sutiles para obtener su ventaja sobre los algoritmos clásicos.
Probablemente también te hayas dado cuenta de lo complicado que puede ser diseñar algoritmos cuánticos. Incluso el primero de todos
requirió mucha creatividad para lograr solo una modesta ventaja sobre los métodos clásicos. Y desde ese primer algoritmo,
físicos e informáticos han seguido ideando formas increíblemente ingeniosas de usar la mecánica cuántica
a su favor, incluidas extensiones y aplicaciones adicionales del algoritmo de Deutsch-Jozsa. Si quieres
aprender sobre algunas de estas, así como probar los algoritmos de Deutsch y Deutsch-Jozsa por ti mismo, visita
el módulo enlazado en la descripción para empezar. Gracias por ver y hasta la próxima.